so that was the turning point for me or
the point of no return to kind of
understand that I have to take just a
step back and that step back was that
the way that I was raised you know I me
and my family went through some
difficult periods during my childhood
and it got to the point where for me and
my mom you know she told me you're my
only hope
you know I'm hoping that you grow up to
be a good Christian son of mine so that
you can get me out of all the challenges
that I faced and so a lot was riding on
my shoulders from the family perspective
I also had my uncles who were trying to
pedigree me towards being intricate part
of the church I'm not saying that I had
to be the next pastor or anything but
definitely involved deeply in the church
so a lot of people had a lot of Hope in
me and what what made me change my mind
is that if I if I had looked at this
whole experience through an emotional
lens I would have definitely never
embraced the song so one one day I was
sitting with one of my friends his name
is Muhammad by the way I'm interestingly
enough and he and I this is after I had
gathered all this information about
other religions as well as Islam and I
knew in my heart that Islam is the
absolute perfect way of life it's what I
want to do so now you're at that plan
I'm at that how far in to your journey
is this is just a few months few years
however approximately how long before
you realize okay this is it this is this
is what I've been saying this is the
truth so I started around 2000 yeah and
it took me about two years to get to
them okay so this is not something just
like overnight no you took your time I'd
really really critical thinking correct
prayer what you know were you asking God
for guidance in yourself or just
reflecting on on things that I knew yeah
things that I understood to be true
things that didn't make sense to me yeah
I was trying to just put all those
things together and kind of thread the
needle to what was real and what was
obviously not real so now you're here
okay so you're about two years into
investigating you know
really doing some critical thinking and
contemplating and so what happens from
there yeah and not just contemplating
but actual research research research I
locked myself up in my parents den and
just was reading books and you know I
would do research on religion I was your
digging man I'm digging okay so I I went
to UIC for the first couple years of my
college 2000-2002 that's by the way
that's where I took my Shahada but while
I was there I was researching so much on
the Dean that you